les églises sont des bijoux
d'architecturé de véritables oeuvres
d'art
les délais sont souvent le lieu des
savoir faire artisanaux les architectes
à la fois des gens qui ont fait les
vitraux les sculptures les stades succès
du travail d'artisan et c'est du travail
qu'il faut mettre en évidence mais ces
derniers temps il ya moins de monde à la
messe certaines églises ont été
désacralisée est transformée en
bibliothèque aux fromageries ou encore
au lieu d' escalade mais d'autres ont
réussi à conserver leur vocation
première en se transformant à l'occasion
en salle de concert
[Musique]
il ya des très belles salles de
spectacles et concerts à montréal
ici c'est un peu dur pour le derrière
liban sont pas nécessairement les plus
confortables mais par contre dès qu'on
élève le regard on en a plein la vue et
et les mêmes notes 1 accueilli ici
parlent différemment que dans une salle
et les paroisses sont de plus en plus
ouvertes à ce genre d'initiative
la fabrique proposera plusieurs concerts
cette année à l'église saint-viateur
d'outremont dont le spectacle de clôture
des journées du patrimoine religieux
et ce qui était un peu spécial mais si
c'est que nous travaillons cette
programmation là avec les commerçants du
coin parce que amener du monde et si ça
amène du monde aussi au commerce des
retombées positives même pour les
visiteurs qui ne sont pas en quête de
spiritualité
même si c'est pas des gens qui viennent
nécessairement l'église régulièrement à
rassembler rassembler connaissement sûr
au niveau de la foi mais ressembler au
niveau de ce qu'on est comme milieu
depuis treize ans le festival pop
montréal a présenté une centaine
d'événements dans des églises
c'est un défi logistique d'utiliser ça
mais l'expérience client qui
s'imbriquent aux festivaliers le
souvenir qu'il crée ça vaut vraiment la
peine d'investir l'île sous et le temps
et l'énergie pour créer ces événements
jusqu'à dimanche les journées du
patrimoine religieux vous invite à
découvrir 70 lieux cultes de 8
confession différente dans ce patrimoine
il y à de belles découvertes ici nabi
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal
[Musique]